Streaming TV shows together has become an
increasingly common activity for couples,
but there are some shows that can lead to
conversations you probably don't want to have.
In the interest of peace, harmony, and your
overall well-being, you definitely want to
steer clear of watching these shows with your
partner.
The protagonists of Bravo's Imposters are
two men and a woman who've all been victims
of a female con artist who tricked them into
falling in love with her, and then disappeared
with all their money.
As they pursue the woman who wronged them
all, they find themselves conning others along
the way, but only those who they believe deserve
it.
Meanwhile, their mutual ex-wife is falling
in love for real, putting her next score at
risk.
"Will you marry me?"
"No."
This is basically a show about how nobody
can really be trusted, and how just because
you're truly in love with someone doesn't
mean their feelings are as sincere as yours.
And if you're going to watch this with your
partner, you'd really better know and trust
them.
Otherwise, if you end up jokingly asking,
"You'd never do that to me, right?" and their
eyes shift just a little, you're never going
to stop thinking about it.
Is it really worth it?
HBO's Divorce is a black comedy in which Sarah
Jessica Parker and Thomas Haden Church play
a middle-aged couple who split up after he
discovers she's had an affair.
Ultimately, there are many other reasons the
two don't belong with each other, but it can
still be jarring to watch a long, seemingly
steady relationship disintegrate and leave
both former partners alone in its aftermath.
If you're a young couple who haven't been
together for all that long, watching Divorce
will have less of an impact.
If you're old enough, on the other hand, and
have been together long enough to have felt
just a little bored in your relationship,
as all couple sometimes do, the show may lead
to questions like "What would you do if we
split up?" or, even worse, "Do you ever think
about getting a divorce?"
No matter how stable your relationship really
is, these conversations are never fun to have.
Black Mirror, which began on the BBC and is
now a Netflix original, is a sci-fi anthology
series which holds an incredibly grim perception
of humanity and the future.
While many episodes don't specifically deal
with relationships, those that do make the
whole prospect seem nothing less than horrifying.
"The Entire History of You" is about a man
obsessed with the possibility that his wife
is cheating on him, in a world where people
can replay anything they've seen.
"Hang the DJ" raises questions about how much
freedom we really have to be with who we want.
"Be Right Back" is about how technology can
make it harder to let go of a partner.
Moreover, Black Mirror is a show that basically
exists to raise uncomfortable questions.
Whether the episode has anything to do with
romance, sometimes discussing hard-hitting
social topics with a romantic partner can
lead to uncomfortable places.
Maybe just watch "San Junipero" together,
and forget the rest of the series ever happened.
Walter White of AMC's Breaking Bad might just
be the worst husband in television history.
He doesn't just lie to his wife: he lies to
his wife about not being a crystal meth cook.
By the time Skyler White finds out what Walt
is really up to, he's already so addicted
to the power of being a criminal mastermind
that he can never really go back to being
a good husband to her.
“If I have to hear one more time that you
did this for the family…"
Not every couple needs to tell each other
everything about their lives, but this show
takes secret-keeping to new and dangerous
heights.
You'll definitely find yourself wondering
what your partner has going on that you don't
know about, and they'll be wondering the same
thing about you.
If you are keeping secrets, that’s not exactly
going to make things comfortable for you.
Netflix's GLOW is mostly a pretty upbeat show
about women's wrestling.
At its center, however, are two best friends
whose relationship has been terribly damaged,
perhaps even irreparably, by a man.
Debbie is married to Mark, and they have a
baby together.
However, Mark is having an affair with Debbie's
best friend Ruth.
Debbie blames Ruth, and Ruth blames herself,
but over the course of the first season it
becomes increasingly clear that Mark is the
real heel.
When Debbie joins Ruth as part of a women's
wrestling TV show, Mark is embarrassed and
unsupportive throughout.
When Debbie reveals at the first live show
that she hasn't given up on wrestling after
all, Mark's derision for Debbie's pursuits
is palpable.
"I’m trying to keep an open mind, it’s
just kinda silly.”
This particular subplot is about how you can
be in a serious relationship without even
realizing that your partner is a terrible
person.
However, unless that's a specific problem
in your relationship in particular, GLOW might
be worth watching together anyway.
No matter how dark its relationship storylines
might be, this is a show that does have a
lot of other cool stuff going on.